ryan seacrest and Shana Taylor have
called it quits again et can confirmed
that the on-again off-again couple has
broken up for the third time but there's
no bad blood here in a statement to ET
Ryan's rep reveals that he and Shana
ended their relationship amicably some
time ago adding that they quote remain
good friends each other's biggest
supporters and will always cherish their
time together as a couple
they are so good meanwhile the 45 year
old TV host was photographed last week
holding hands with a mystery woman while
on vacation in Cabo San Lucas Mexico but
back to Ryan and Shana the two were
first linked in 2013 after meeting
through mutual friends you know on a on
a Friday night you got it you got it fit
you fit in the date night on a Friday
night - you know they first broke up in
late 2014 only to later rekindle things
last February et reported that Ryan and
scheana had split again but nearly six
months later they were spotted together
in Positano Italy Ryan Seacrest and
Kelly Ripa you're on the air with us
while hosting live with Kelly and Ryan
in May Seacrest wished Shana a happy
third anniversary explaining that it was
their third time together quote so we've
gotten together broken up gotten
together broken up this is number three
of being together so we're celebrating
that as well
when co-host Kelly Ripa suggested
Seacrest third time with the 28 year old
could be the charm
Ryan replied quote listen nothing's
perfect you just keep trying until you
get it right
meanwhile here's what Seacrest told et
about the future of his relationship
back in December 2018 your sister got
married not too long ago you know the
family putting any pressure on you you
need to put a ring on it no here's the
good news about my family they're so
distracted that my sister's having a
baby in about three days
they don't even know I exist and at the
time the live with Kelly and Ryan
co-host was just excited about becoming
an uncle I'm practicing with
you know it's just different objects how
to hold you know how to hold babies so I
think I've got it down so therefore you
know I'm excited about it
[Music]